[Musik]
in Deutschland gelten rund 13 Millionen
Menschen als arm oder von Armut bedroht
uns steht das Wasser nicht mehr bis zum
Hals wir sind mitten im absaufen
karitative Einrichtungen wie die Tafeln
kommen an ihre Grenzen
so dass man mich mal bei Suppenküche
sieht Ende des Monats weil es einfach
nicht reicht von unten
wer kein Geld hat ist oft einsam
unglücklich
[Musik]
Dortmund Nordstadt ein sozialer
Brennpunkt viel Kriminalität hohe
Arbeitslosigkeit und Armut
wer hier ansteht hat Hunger es sind
viele und werden von Tag zu Tag mehr
Menschen denen das Geld ausgeht die
nicht genug zu essen haben mitten in
Deutschland
bei dem Wetter danke Alexander geht auf
eine private tontechnikerschule letzten
Monat war er zum ersten Mal bei der
Suppenküche
die Frau die mir das Essen ausgegeben
hat die hat mir das einfach angesehen
das war so eine ältere Omi quasi
und der hat gesehen dass ich mich schäme
und sagt dann so zu mir Hunger hat sein
Recht
Alexander 30 hat 615 € im Monat Hartz IV
Regelsatz plus Minijob davon bezahlt er
190 € Schulgeld 160 € an Fixkosten es
bleiben 265 € zum Leben
ursprünglich war die Suppenküche vor
allem ein Projekt für Obdachlose nun ist
sie auch Anlaufstelle für all die
Menschen bei denen das Geld nicht reicht
Annalena arbeitet ehrenamtlich hier es
wird schlimmer wie die Gästezahlen
steigen wir geben immer mehr Portionen
raus und haben auch immer mehr ja wir
sehen auch einfach mehr Verzweiflung bei
unseren Gästen der nordmarktpark
Treffpunkt für Dealer und Junkies der
Nordstadt
alexander ist in der Gegend aufgewachsen
Schlägereien Diebstahl Jugendstrafen
gehörten früher zu seinem Leben nun will
er studieren sound engineer werden
doch er hat nur einen
Hauptschulabschluss deshalb muss er
erstmal ein Vorstudium machen das kostet
Schulgeld Bafög gibt es dafür keines ja
andere sitzen irgendwo im Restaurant ja
schön noch einen sunpellegrino bestellen
und ich sitze mit einer Suppe von einer
Suppenküche und guckt die Junkies bei
ihrem Turkey Zug ja das ist Nordstadt
quasi die Nordstadt hat das Leben von
Alexander geprägt er hatte die falschen
Freunde es fehlte jemand Vorbildern
seine alleinerziehende Mutter war
überfordert das Jugendamt schickte ihn
nach Portugal in eine Pflegefamilie kaum
war ich ein Jahr ein portugal hat sich
komplett bei mir im Kopf was verändert
ja das hat wirklich was gebracht wenn er
hier in der Nordstadt bist und aufwächst
dann
und du änderst deinen Ort nicht
bleiben dir nicht viele Chancen weil das
Umfeld beeinflusst einen einfach
zum Umfeld gehören Menschen wie Martin
und Jürgen
aus meiner Eickeler Dortmund gezogen ja
1994 bei dem wohne ich auch hier ja und
dann habe ich leider nur ja Leute
kennengelernt und ich habe gemerkt dass
ich über ihn das vergisst du alles das
tut mir gut
ich nehme immer noch alles was ich
kriegen kann
Methadon alleine schon ich bin der 22
Jahre mit der Lohnprogramm
seit fast 30 Jahren ist der Nordmarkt
ihr zweites Zuhause aber so richtig gut
gefällt es Ihnen hier nicht mehr ja das
ist schon das ist alles
und hier ist einfach der soziale
Brennpunkt sag ich mal so die Leute
haben kein Geld mehr und die Klauen sich
gegenseitig das letzte
geben würde werde ich wahrscheinlich
auch nicht hier verkehren aber ich
irgendwo zieht mich dann auch hier hin
weil ich nur so eine Leute kennen ich
bin unter Drogensüchtigen groß geworden
in Bochum geht Gaby Alexander zur Tafel
seit einem Dreivierteljahr holt sie sich
ihr Lebensmittel ich war mein Leben lang
Krankenschwester bin jetzt berentet und
mein Mann ist krank geworden er hatte
einen Schlaganfall und jetzt sind wir
halt Hartz IV Empfänger
Gabriele Alexander 64 ihre Rente 1346
Euro ihr Ehemann bekommt Hartz IV
zusammen haben sie 1626 Euro für
Lebensmittel bleiben 190 €
die Tafel in Bochum etwa 600 Menschen
versorgen sie allein hier bei der
Zentrale für die Lebensmittel steht man
im Schnitt zwei Stunden an so mancher
Politiker der sollte das mal wirklich
zwei drei Monate machen
da wird sich vielleicht irgendwie was an
der Denkweise ändern
acht Wagenladungen werden hier täglich
angeliefert die Spenden kommen von den
umliegenden Händlern aber das reicht
nicht die Tafeln in Deutschland
versorgen zurzeit so viele Menschen wie
noch nie seit Anfang des Jahres ein
Anstieg von
50%. der Vorsitzende Stefan Schulze und
seine Mitarbeiter in Bochum mussten
schon hunderte abweisen die Nachfrage
ist stark gestiegen so dass wir in
Aufnahmestopp einführen mussten weil wir
einfach nicht genug Lebensmittel haben
am Ende eines ausgabetages sind wir
faktisch leer vielleicht das noch eine
halbe Kiste übrig dann von hunderten die
hier durchgehen jeden Tag danke schön
Gabi bekommt für den symbolischen Betrag
von 4 € reichlich frische Produkte bei
der Tafel gibt es vor allem Ware die
nicht so lange haltbar ist die von den
Supermärkten aussortiert wurde
[Musik]
die Ration reicht Gaby etwa für vier
Tage
ich wüsste nicht was ich machen sollte
ohne Tafel bei mir im Haus wo ich wohne
da willst du das eigentlich alle ich
gehe da ganz offen mit um weil ich muss
mich da ja nicht schämen also ich habe
ja mein Leben lang gearbeitet und wenn
wir halt in so einer Situation sind dann
ist das so ne
mit den Lebensmitteln geht sie nach
Hause per S und Straßenbahn braucht sie
fast eine Stunde dafür hat sie sich
einen Sozialticket gekauft es kostet
knapp 40 Euro im Monat viel Geld für
Gabi und ihren Mann
alles was was da außergewöhnliche
Ausgabe ist da muss man sparen sondern
habe ich am Hintern überlegt und mit
meinem Mann auch gesprochen und dann ja
dann kauf dir das Ticket
[Musik]
freundlich tue ich mich immer über Obst
also anders Mango das würde ich mir
wahrscheinlich gar nicht kaufen heute
gibt's dann Kartoffeln Bohnen
und
Bratwürstchen Rostbratwürstchen morgen
mache ich Eintopf der reicht für zwei
Tage
aber erstmal gibt es eine Vorspeise die
Macht Gabi für sich und ihren Mann
jörg hat seinen Job während Corona
verloren jetzt arbeitet er zwar verdient
aber kaum etwas das ist ein
zwei-euro-job
früher war es ein Euro Job und ich fahre
für eine Verein ist das hier in Bochum
da hole ich Kleider ab 244 Euro
verdienst du da ne und davon geht mehr
als die Hälfte für Sprit drauf
nur um zur Arbeit zu kommen habe über 40
Jahre Küchen montiert da ihr wohl so
reinrutschen das ist nicht mehr mit dem
Schlaganfall und Knie kaputt Rücken
kaputt vom Tragen und
also da ist nicht mehr dran zu denken
[Musik]
Berlin Hellersdorf nach sechs Stunden
hatte Alex Schulschluss er besucht die
Sekundarschule und gehört zu den guten
Schülern
meine Lieblingsfächer sind Mathe Kunst
und Musik schwer fällt mir Englisch und
versuche mich da zu verbessern
nach Hause geht er noch nicht er braucht
neue Sachen und hat Hunger
alex ist 15 Jahre alt 10 klässler die
Familie bezieht Hartz IV sein Ziel
Journalismus studieren
den Nachmittag verbringt er bei der
Arche einer christlichen
Hilfsorganisation zur Unterstützung von
Kindern und Jugendlichen
hallo Alex na brauchst du neue Sachen ja
am besten neue schöne neue Jacke in der
Schatzkiste kann sich Alex einmal im
Monat einige gespendete Kleidungsstücke
aussuchen
die sitzen sehr gut sehr gut
oder eher was neutraleres
hier ist sehr gut
die Sachen sind funktional aber
gebraucht sehr gerne in den Laden gehen
und mir einfach den Pulli aussuchen den
ich gerade gerne haben möchte
keine Ahnung sortieren und sagen hier
denen hätte ich gerne den poliert dich
gern und direkt so kaufen da das aber
wegen dem Geld nicht funktioniert muss
ich erst in die Schatzkiste gehen und ja
schauen ob wir es da irgendwie bekommen
die Mitschüler die können sich meistens
Sachen selbst kaufen und müssen nicht
hierher gehen
Stör ich das dann oder wie wie
empfindest du das
ja also stört mich nicht wirklich
die haben deren Leben ich habe mein
Leben
jeden Tag erhalten Kinder deren Eltern
Hartz IV beziehen in der Arche eine
kostenlose warme Mahlzeit in letzter
Zeit hat die Nachfrage stark zugenommen
bei den Familien mit denen wir arbeiten
ist die regelmäßige Versorgung mit Essen
tatsächlich sehr wichtiges Thema wir
merken dass es nicht selbstverständlich
ist dass jeder Jugendliche jedes Kind
mit einem vollen Bauch ins Bett geht
oder auch zur Schule geht um sich dort
angemessen konzentrieren zu können
[Musik]
später gibt es Hausaufgabenbetreuung
alex ist gut in Mathe ein paar Fragen
hat er dennoch
und das ist eine Binomische Form zwei
Zahlen und Plus und in Klammern zum
Quadrat schreibt es erstmal am besten
hin für mich ist sehr wichtig gut in der
Schule zu sein da ich mein Abitur machen
möchte Bildung kann sehr vieles
verändern was die zukünftige Laufbahn
angeht
ohne Bildung hat man weniger Chancen auf
dem Arbeitsmarkt als mit Bildung
der 15-Jährige weiß auf was es ankommt
und wie er Hartz IV hinter sich lassen
kann
[Musik]
Freitagnachmittag an der Suppenküche
Dortmund Hochbetrieb auch Alexander
steht in der Schlange
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich wieder hier habe sogar
noch mein Keyboard einstecken ja weil
ich gleich noch ins Krankenhaus muss
das kriegst du dafür 30 Euro quasi
Drittel von dem was es wert ist warum
machst du das jetzt für Geld ja das Ende
des Monats jetzt stehe ich wieder hier
an eine Suppenküche holen wir meinen
Teller ab quasi und so habe ich dann
noch ein bisschen Geld in der Tasche zum
Einkaufen ne
gegessen wird wo es gerade geht
inmitten des Straßenverkehrs
[Musik]
auch Stefanie und Patrick stellen sich
an beide leben von Hartz IV dadurch ist
alles teurer geworden ist können wir uns
das nicht mehr leisten jeden Tag zu
kochen so Einrichtungen wo man halt
einmal am Tag für eine warme Mahlzeit
kriegt ist schon sehr komfortabel die
zwei erwarten ein Kind sie hatte als
Jugendliche eine psychische Krise er hat
früher gedealt die Vergangenheit hängt
beiden bis heute nach ich habe diverse
Vorstrafen
und bin durch meinen ganzen Akten als
schwer vermittelbar
so ist halt ein kleiner mehr ein nicht
mal mehr zum Probearbeiten das habe ich
versucht als das noch ganz am Anfang war
zum August hin weil es die ganzen
Ausbildungen zu angefangen haben jetzt
die Bäckerei wollte mich nicht mehr
Stefanie ist 31 Patrick 34 seit elf
Jahren sind sie ein Paar sie wollen eine
Familie gründen beide sind
langzeitarbeitslos
nach einer Dreiviertelstunde warten sind
Sie dran die Leute die an einem
vorbeilaufen
behandeln einen schon schlechter also
man hat schon das Gefühl dass ich von
oben herab auf einen runter gucken also
man man fühlt sich
Bürger zweiter Klasse so richtig
ihre Wohnung ist nicht weit weg die
Mahlzeit draußen im Nordstadt Milieu
bleibt ihnen erspart
stefanie hat eine Ausbildung zur
Alltagsbegleiterin für Senioren gemacht
Patrick Dachdecker und Metzger gelernt
reguläre Arbeit hatten beide schon lange
nicht mehr wenn sie Jobs bekamen dann
als Maßnahmen des Arbeitsamtes zu
geringen Stundenlöhnen das Mittagessen
für Bedürftige ist keine Dauerlösung für
die werdende Familie
stellen das ist auch auf jeden Fall
warum
und weil das gar nicht erst damit groß
werden soll
auch nicht in diesem Umfeld an pöbelnden
Menschen natürlich nicht mein Kind mit
rein wir sind jetzt schon nach Wohnungen
am gucken dass wir hier aus diesem Stadt
gern rausziehen also das Kind
[Musik]
wird schon in ländlichen Umgebungen groß
das hier ist zu
Ghetto
ich habe keinen Bock dass mein Kind hier
hinten in irgendeinem Nordstadt
kindergartenkindergarten geht und das
erste was das Kind lernt ist
wahrscheinlich [ __ ] Spruch
bislang blieb die Wohnungssuche
erfolglos für ihr Leben als kleine
Familie haben sie noch nicht viel
vorbereitet
macht mir alles leere gleich viel Angst
mit dem Kind also auf das jetzt
finanziell gesehen ist oder
emotional das ist ungefähr alles gleich
aufregend
das Sozialkaufhaus der Caritas in
Dortmund viele Möbelstücke haben
Stefanie und Patrick hier gekauft
Kleidung bisher nicht secondhand fürs
Neugeborene Hauptsache preiswert
das ist niedlich
das passiert Jungs und zum Mädchen in
Grün das ist schön das gefällt mir passt
doch direkt
ob ich selber möchte halt nicht
unbedingt gebrauchte Klamotten tragen
und gerade weil ich ein Kind war was
immer halt Sachen von vorher gekriegt
hat
spiegelt sich das glaube ich halt so mir
wieder dass ich das schön finde wenn ich
mir selber neue Klamotten kaufen
als Hartz IV Empfänger wurden ihnen vom
Amt 418 € für die Baby Erstausstattung
zugesagt das muss für alles reichen
Kleidung Kinderwagen Wickelkommode und
Bettchen 418 € ist für wenn man die
Sachen neu kauft und also mir halt nicht
hier hingeht sondern dazu Ikea oder so
glaube ich kommt man da nicht so weit
mit den Kinderzimmereinrichtung ja
normalerweise sind die alle
ausgezeichnet 50 € haben sie eine Kunden
sind noch 20%
eine Wiege für 40 Euro ein Anfang für
ihre Zukunft als Familie
Werner rund 20 Kilometer von Dortmund
entfernt alexander ist mit dem Zug
gekommen er will ins Jugendzentrum Musik
machen das Geld für die Fahrkarte hatte
er nicht
heute wurde ich einfach erwischt der auf
dem Weg hier zeigt wieder 60 Euro man
muss so sagen ich führen ganz
bürgerliches Leben bis sie bis zur
Hälfte des Monats und dann fängt an so
okay dann diese Woche okay dann hole ich
mir mal nur Kochbeutel rein so ein
bisschen Putenfleisch dann war's das ja
dann verzichte ich auf Paprika dafür
fahre ich aber dann ein bisschen schwarz
und so halt solche Filme man muss halt
gucken wo man bleibt
im Jugendzentrum Juwel lernt der
30-Jährige zunächst für die
tontechnikschule wöchentlich 20 Stunden
umfasst die Online-Ausbildung bei der er
Studiotechnik liftechnik und
Musikproduktion lernt mit dem Abschluss
kann er dann studieren es geht eine
darum du dir zu haben und Bachelor zu
haben ich habe sonst nur ein
Hauptschulabschluss mein Ziel ist jetzt
erstmal mein diploma Anfang nächsten
Jahres zu beenden dann bin ich erstmal
zertifizierte audio engineer und da
möchte ich mein Bachelor anfangen
creative media
als Tonmeister oder Musikmanager könnte
er dann arbeiten die Hausaufgabe heute
Soundmischung
den Entschluss für diesen Ausbildungsweg
fällt der Alexander als er vor vier
Jahren Vater wurde
meine Zwillingssöhne soll mir ja nicht
sagen ja papa du hast auch nichts
gelernt der doch ich habe was gelernt so
für euch mache ich das ja sonst würde
ich doch auch darauf scheißen würde ich
dann irgendwie was anderes machen je
nachdem was weiß ich ich ziehe das jetzt
so durch weil man muss tun was man liebt
sonst wissen im Leben kein Erfolg haben
Nick ist einer der Schüler denen er das
Rappen beibringt bislang auf
ehrenamtlicher Basis hast du schon ein
schönes gebaut für uns ja ja
[Musik]
es kann über Wasser und durch Wände
gehen kotzen um mit denen was ist der
perfekt und kann sogar dem missverstehen
gefällt dir der ja das ist cool willst
du haben ja
Nein schenke ich dir
für seinen Schüler geht Alexander ans
Mikro wird zu jasam Adam dem Rapper
die Musik
hat mir auf jeden Fall beigebracht
ich habe nichts aber ich bin was
Rentnerin Gabi macht Besorgungen im
Supermarkt hier bekommt sie die Sache
die es bei der Tafel nicht gibt zum
Beispiel haltbare Lebensmittel wie
Nudeln Reis Kondensmilch Kaffee oder
Mehl am besten im Sonderangebot ich
gucke auch zu Hause in den
reklamedingern wo was günstig ist und
wenn ich das dann benötige dann fahre
ich da auch tatsächlich hin ich fahre
also auch in mehrere Läden dann
aber vieles kauft sie gar nicht mehr
weil der Preis dauerhaft zu hoch ist da
heißt es nach günstigen Alternativen
suchen eigentlich esse ich lieber Butter
aber Butter ist ja dermaßen teuer
geworden die kann ich gar nicht mehr
kaufen und wenn deswegen kaufe ich
Margarine aber die günstige Margarine
hier ist weg da gehe ich dann in einen
anderen Laden gucken
[Applaus]
ein absolutes Muss ist für sie
Kondensmilch auch die ist teuer geworden
ich habe irgendwann mal 50 Cent für eine
Packung Kondensmilch bezahlt dann 60
sind und jetzt bezahle ich dafür 99 also
das ist schon eine Nummer ich würde auch
normal voll Milch nehmen aber mein Mann
ist ein bisschen empfindlich mit seinem
Kaffee und deswegen glaube ich für ihn
Kondensmilch
beim Einkauf für sich und ihren Mann
muss sie auf die Preise achten ihre
niedrige Rente bestimmt ihren Alltag
300 Euro okay wenn mein Mann seine Rente
kriegt kommt man mit klar aber man kommt
auch nur mit klar man kann da also ja
keine was weiß ich machen
ja da fühlt man sich vom Staat ein
bisschen verlassen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Alexander geht in Berlin zur
Demonstration der Initiative Hashtag ich
bin armuts betroffen vor einigen Monaten
haben Menschen die finanziell kaum über
die Runden kommen die Gruppe gegründet
Kundgebung vor dem Kanzleramt
ich glaube es ist an der Zeit dass auch
ganz normale Menschen einfach mal zeigen
dass die Umstände in Deutschland zurzeit
einfach nicht tragbar sind und dass man
auch mal auf die Straße gehen ich habe
nicht mehr viel Feuer
Arm seines teuer
Deutschland haben
Leute die
auch und das wissen die meisten Menschen
einfach nicht mit dem Arbeitslosengeld 2
Satz den wir als Familie beziehen als
Bedarfsgemeinschaft ein ist nicht mehr
möglich ist einfach zurecht zu kommen
und ähm ich möchte dass meine Kinder
genau die gleichen Chancen haben wie die
anderen Kinder deren Eltern sich mehr
leisten können
und da hatte Mädchen so ein Herzschild
ich bin von Armut betroffen und es
reicht nicht für gesundes Essen ich bin
selber mit meinem kleinen Bruder
alleinerziehende Mutter aufgewachsen ich
weiß wie das ist wenn man wenig hat und
dass das Geld für gesunde Ernährung
nicht reicht da kannst du den Cent noch
zehn mal umdrehen es reicht einfach
nicht ein paar hundert sind gekommen
obwohl 500.000 unter dem Hashtag ich bin
Armut betroffen etwas geschrieben haben
[Applaus]
viele können sich eine Fahrt nach Berlin
einfach nicht leisten
und auch aus der Anonymität heraus
alexander hat eine kostenlose
Mitfahrgelegenheit nur deswegen ist er
hier er meint die Reise habe sich
gelohnt
sind die super erster man lernt Menschen
kennen die in derselben Situation sind
und man fühlt sich nicht mehr so alleine
das Schamgefühl dass man wenig Geld zur
Verfügung hat verfliegt auch man merkt
einfach es sind so viele betroffen es
war die erste Demonstration der
Initiative weitere sollen folgen
Berlin
Alex hilft seiner Mutter die
Lebensmittel von der Tafel nach Hause zu
bringen
Jessica Lauer kann wegen
gesundheitlicher Beschwerden in ihrem
Beruf als Lackiererin nicht mehr
arbeiten
sie spart wo sie kann was das für ihren
Sohn bedeutet bereitet ihr manchmal
Sorgen ich denke mal zwischendurch ist
es schwer für Alex aber er lässt es mich
nicht so spüren geschweige denn macht
mir deswegen Vorwürfe sondern er
akzeptiert wie es ist unterstützt mich
wo es geht
der Zehntklässler muss noch lernen in
einigen Tagen schreibt er eine
Klassenarbeit und die soll gut ausfallen
die meisten seiner Mitschüler müssen
sich nicht so einschränken wie er
wir hatten halt nie ein besseres Leben
für mich ist dass sie sozusagen der
normal stand alles was besser ist sehe
ich als ja mehr Geld sozusagen an
allerdings weiß ich auch dass
mir ist auch besser geht als vielleicht
manche anderen die es noch härter trifft
aber sonst so kann ich nichts vermissen
was ich nicht hatte
das wichtigste ist er hat eine Mama die
ihn liebt er kann zur Schule gehen er
hat immer essen da also er muss nicht
hungern die wichtigsten Sachen die er
für sein späteres Leben braucht die
kriegt da und alles andere wird mit der
Zeit kommen
am Abend hat Alex Training
der Vereinsbeitrag wird über das
teilhabepaket des Bundes finanziert
seit einem Jahr spielt er mit
Begeisterung im athletik-club Berlin
Volleyball
[Musik]
also beim Sport kann ich mich sehr gut
auspowern das ist sozusagen die
lastbefreiung für mich also
wenn ich Stress vom Park habe beim Sport
denke ich an nichts anderes als den
Sport der das Geld im Hintergrund
[Musik]
in der Nordstadt Dortmund sind viele
Menschen auf die Großzügigkeit anderer
angewiesen Marcel lebt von Spenden und
vom Verkauf einer Straßenzeitung
zur Zeit bin ich wohnungslos also ich
darf zurzeit beim Kollegen bei auf der
Couch zum Glück sag ich jetzt mal aber
ich habe vier Jahre auf der Straße
gelebt ich habe hier unten mein Zelt
stehen gehabt
und ja bin jetzt ganz froh dass ich
jetzt über den Winter jetzt endlich
meinen warenplatz hat
der 39-Jährige war Drogenabhängig wegen
Beschaffungskriminalität saß er im
Gefängnis lebte dann vom Betteln auf der
Straße seit einem Jahr ist der clean und
will zurück in ein normales Leben Hartz
IV hat er beantragt noch wartet er auf
die Bewilligung
Marcels Haupteinnahmequelle ist der
Verkauf der Zeitung Bodo
eine jawohl freut mich dann gehen und
wir versuchen beim Lesen ciao
einen schönen Abend
wir sehen halt auch dass man nicht so
dumm rumsitzen
man ist auf Augenhöhe das ist eh ganz
was ganz anderes und ja und wer hat
alleine mir weil sowas ist mir Gutes
getan hat ist halt auch wieder die
Struktur zu kriegen einen wunderschönen
guten Tag die Dame hätten täglich vier
bis fünf Stunden steht er hier
gerne
ich danke ihnen 52 Hälfte für die
Redaktion und die Hälfte ist für mich
ich danke Ihnen beim Lesen einen schönen
Tag noch alles Gute ciao
einmal will ich natürlich ihm was gutes
tun ich sehen fast täglich und
inhaltlich ist das auch was in der
Wohnung steht
nicht jeder zückt so selbstverständlich
den Geldbeutel
in Fraktion Merkel natürlich merkt man
das natürlich auch die Gaspreise
gestiegen sind also in diesem Monat habe
ich weniger verkauft als noch vor zwei
Monaten damals kann man sagen habe ich
am Tag so 10 20 Zeitung verkauft jetzt
wenn ich glück gehabt bekomme ich fünf
bis sieben ja wenn ich Glück habe ganz
viel Glück zwischen 7,50 € und 10,50 €
nimmt er damit ein
[Musik]
also klauen gehen habe ich keine Lust
mehr irgendwann wieder ein Haft zu
fahren ehrlich Geld verdienen statt wie
früher auf kriminelle Weise in Zeiten
wachsende Armut immer schwieriger am
Abend trifft er seinen Freund Patrick
ebenfalls Ex-Junkie
beide teilen das gleiche Schicksal nach
der Haftentlassung gab es keine Hilfe
weder bei der Wohnungssuche noch beim
Beantragen von Hartz IV erst mit dem
Verkauf der Zeitung Bodo begann die
soziale Beratung durch den dazugehörigen
Verein bis alle bürokratischen Hürden
genommen sind bleiben sie abhängig von
knapper werdenden Verkaufserlösen und
Spenden
immerhin reicht es heute für ein warmes
Abendessen
das ist das schwierigste dich aufzugeben
und halt wieder irgendwie dort zu hängen
wo man im Jahr hat das heißt
Drogen
Kriminalität
dieser Szene wir sehen uns hier am Laden
also auf der Straße aber die
Freundschaft ist schon sehr wichtig weil
ich meine viele Zeit alleine
[Musik]
glücklich natürlich und deswegen ist es
gerade wichtig sozialen Kontakt zu sein
ja
[Musik]
wir sehen uns
schönen Abend auf Marcel wartet eine
Couch im warmen für seinen Freund nicht
er hat keine Bleibe
gute Nachrichten für Alexander seine
Arbeit im Jugendzentrum wird künftig
entlohnt damit hat er 200 Euro mehr im
Monat
das Geld fürs Ehrenamt wird ihm nicht
von Hartz IV abgezogen und er hat sein
erstes rap-video
das hat sich auf jeden Fall gelohnt
weiterzumachen nicht einfach Kopf in den
Sand stecken sondern weiter und
das wird belohnt auf jeden Fall du bist
alleine in der schwersten Zeit
du musst brauchst du jetzt aus
Eisen ja
du bist alleine in der schwersten Zeit
du musst lernen